[Music]
okay
here goes nothing
[Music]
welcoming committee maybe this won't be
so bad okay first day on the job make
eye contact smile
[Applause]
it's a dog he's gonna ruin everything
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
hi
[Music]
are you really a dog yes i am a dog told
you um
i didn't know dogs could be samurai well
they can and i
wait why not your sword's on backwards
no it's not actually is it
do you know how this is supposed to go i
know a few things about samurai fair
enough i'll bet i deputize you as my
official assistant
bad dog don't talk to him did you touch
him time to use our hand sanitizers
what's that the blindfold is to help you
focus
ah now listen tell me what you hear i
hear you talking and moving good i hear
a bird
that's it i smell flowers actually dogs
have a keen sense of smell and excellent
hearing i hear a dragonfly
[Music]
i smell wood burning
smell tea brewing
are you making nachos cause someone just
cut the cheese
lesson over
well done
defend yourself
what am i supposed to do with a stick
lesson one it is not so important what
you do as it is important that you do
something a warrior has cat like reflex
i'm not a cat i'm a dog nobody's perfect
wait that music
hey this is the training montage isn't
it hey can't we just skip ahead to the
part where i'm good no this is my
favorite part part where you suffer
wait that music this is the training
montage isn't it
[Music]
wow did not see that coming
[Music]
[Music]
pause of fury
ready pg
[Music]
he has told you his weakness remember
you defeat strength for smart but get
back outside
[Music]
summer hank needs your help
are you not bound by your summary oath
to help him you mean the one that says i
can't turn my back on those in need yeah
that one
no
maybe
that's not what
stupid oh
the cuteness is strong with this one
work work work let's see what's on the
agenda today cat fights on the western
front cat's scratch fever breaking out
in the east what's this a sacred soil
has been soiled by a dog who crossed the
border probably a border collie
fortunately he's been apprehended oh
well you break the law you pay the price
it's not personal it's just business and
you know what they say there's no
business like shogun business
i know these events look dire but we
must stand on our own four legs and
fight this is our home
it is the sacred place where our kittens
were born and where we will one day join
our ancestors
in a shoebox buried behind the garage
dr katz you have something to say no i
just got a hairball
how's everything coming along the shogun
is coming to visit in one week everyone
knows he's trying to decide who his
successor will be and if i have anything
to do with it it'll be me i spared no
expense making this the grandest palace
in the land imported mice to chase find
couches to ruin and the crown jewel of
the palace my state-of-the-art bathroom
behold the future
i call it the super bowl because that's
what it is a super bowl impressive
okay now this will be difficult it might
take a while so let's split up
i'll take the areas to the north and
west you go south and east let's try to
be methodical about this there could be
thousands of cells here and this could
take hours maybe days
he's right over here
hey sumo we're here to save you
guess we should have stolen some keys
stand back
well at least you tried
doggy door
the only thing left to solve is our
little problem
precisely what do you do when you're a
landlord and you have tenants you really
hate you evict them but the town's been
there for thousands of years i give you
an order and you give me fats really the
only fact i'm interested in is that that
hair ball of a town is ruining my
magnificent view we've got to wipe them
off a map in order to make this palace
absolutely perfect but what about the
samurai that's there to protect them
just get rid of their samurai the friday
cats will follow
remember fear
is only in your mind and a little bit in
my kimono
greetings human people i am emiko i know
[Applause]
clean up after us
pamper us oh me likey and feta are you
making nachos cause someone just cut the
cheese
no it sounds like nothing new it's
because we've always been in charge
impressive do not resist our cuteness
can be deadly ready to go let me go
mom you're embarrassing me
why do you want to be a samurai
i lived in a bad part of town full of
bad dogs
everybody always picked on me
i thought if i could be a samurai
it would change everything
sounds like you need a mentor perhaps a
once great samurai who has fallen on
hard times maybe could use some help
himself
but where can i find one
get out of here who even made that
it's you don't believe everything you
read
[Music]
sorry hank you have to do something
you're under arrest
you wanted to be a samurai fun isn't it
get back out there
[Music]
when you come up on that lick make sure
hey this is the training montage isn't
it sometimes you need a friend
[Applause]
nope
don't forget to land on your
feet
[Music]
send a tweet to assemble the troops
who knew an evil army could go through
so many beams
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what the mother father cocker spaniel's
going on here
the legend of hank
time to finish this
this might take a while
[Music]